what's up guys did you know it's the
year of the rock Dwayne the rock Johnson
is in like every movie including pain
and gain which opens this weekend
paramount was cool enough to invite us
to the world premiere screening and
press junket where we could rub butts
with all the stars including the rock
fans of the show know that there's a
rock fan amongst us and his name is Nick
Mundy we already had Rock'em Sock'em
robots but the rock that you say that
about every movie well yeah because the
rock is awesome here's the thing Nick is
seriously obsessed with the rock so in
spite of Paramount's concerns we are
sending an obsessed rock
superfan with no junket experience down
to Miami to meet the rock
I'm here to interview the rock do you
like the rock do you know where he lives
looking on stairs and figure out a
couple of things one where's the rock -
is that bridge where Tia Carrere died in
True Lies holy king the rough is
incredible
in pain and gain it's the best movie
I've seen in 10 years he's totally
ripped he's doing cocaine he's got like
the skateboard he's just carrying around
it's [ __ ] awesome I want to go on I'm
gonna go I'm getting nervous I'll be
honest I'm getting really really nervous
I'm scared they know like I don't know
what I'm doing I know just because it's
my first time doing this um oh cool yeah
I'm really nervous I get to be my idol
in a few minutes like the rock you're
right yeah yeah you're gonna do great
the rock just like delivered this insane
fantastic performance if you guys could
be an attack team with the rock what
would your names be me no I got
questions they're gonna make me answers
so is heyou cool screen junkies my name
is NIC Mundy don't [ __ ] this up I don't
do that first I gotta say I'm just a
huge fan I've been a fan of yours for 15
years that's why they sent me this is
not the first time we met actually met
you at the Houston summit well the
hooters across from Houston summit they
wouldn't know you didn't house show they
won't let a 15 year old pay for your
bills so I don't know what mr. Johnson
had but I tried to pay for the bill and
I had it all in like he was like no no
I'll take care of it like a gentleman
you're a class act so wow I wonder how
you would be a violation
paid for my meal I saw I'm gonna talk
about painting oh no no no LOC no I
appreciate you're gonna hear about her
okay I saw the movie and holy it's
amazing what's it like being in the best
movie in like the last 10 years maybe
ever I mean it's just exciting this has
been an absolute pleasure I really
appreciate it thank you thank you thank
you took your phone oh yeah
holy did I just spit the rock just let
my childhood hero gasp guess the rock
Wow now you're gonna ask 20 slim
questions and I don't know what to ask
him he's in wings right
I just met my hero downstairs the rock
and now I'm meeting you and I'm a big
fan and it's thank you it's just it's
great what's it like being in the best
movie in the last like 10 years like no
yeah oh oh well that's so great to hear
oh it's amazing it's exciting I mean
it's exciting to work on a project to
work on a kid tony shalhoub was nice and
all but I couldn't stop thinking about
meeting the rock that guy's awesome
I love the rock wanna be friends with
the wrong did you see his muscles no
they were pretty good friends this has
been the greatest trip ever in my life I
met the rock his friend Mad Dog me I
made an atoll of myself in front of Tony
Shalhoub I want to go home and sleep
this has been my trip I'm NIC Mundy for
screen junkies by the way we get to talk
about junket people they're weird wow so
I guess Paramount will never have
invited us to a junket again
yeah the interviews didn't go great I
got a little nervous actually the head
of marketing said it was the worst
interview she's ever seen in the history
of her career so team Wahlberg really
was giving you the stink eye you know in
his defense I didn't make eye contact
with them or ask him any questions or
really acknowledge him at all but you
know this was my opportunity to really
meet the rock and I just you know wanted
to make the best of it now you made
something of it
thank you thank you screen jackets for
making dreams come true that's all we do
hey who are you a super fan of who would
you flip out over meeting would it be
Haley Joel Osment or Dame Judi Dench or
the rock yeah let us know in the
comments below and tell us what you
would do when you came face-to-face with
them and the best answer get the screen
junkies t-shirt this is NIC Mundy I'm
Hal rod NIC
[Music]